But like a,
we get a lot of like,
how do I make it or when's the right time to move to la or New York?
Never or whatever.
But yeah,
but it's the eighties it's like,
I don't know man.
It's,
it's Kinda up to you.
And this guy who's like,
I've been doing it like 12 years or something and Andrew was just like
[inaudible] to finished.
She goes,
I would give up,
man.
I would honestly give up because this business will eat you alive.
And I don't,
and that is something,
I don't have the heart.
I'm a sensitive guy.
I don't have the heart to say that to anyone to just say back it up and can move
on.
You're editing for you.
You know?
But Andrew was saying that and it was kind of like,
yeah,
we were,
I appreciated his honesty.
You know?
Well,
like I,
I just think that it requires an obsession.
Yes.
If you're not like fully obsessed,
you're probably not going to put the thought process and the effort and do,
and you're not going to survive.
The bombings know the bombings.
Like they test your soul.
It's just nothing worse than feeling that amount of hate.
Where,
where,
where I or being in New York and to dead silence and hearing a guy in the back
button would be like,
oh,
you fucking kidding me.
Can we fucking go home now?
I mean,
Jesus Christ like audibly,
audibly,
and the
silence.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I just,
and I hear that guy in my dreams and just bombing on stage once and this guy
goes,
you're fucking terrible.
And I was like,
he's right.
It's nothing I could say.
I can't never respond.
Like,
not not going to say,
dude,
I'm with you.
I can't even pull myself out of this.
Yeah.
I got nothing.
Dave,
I were a Patton Oswald being on stage at the first festival ever did.
It was a Chicago comedy festival and I found,
I found the booklet from it recently,
like cleaning out my house and,
uh,
2001 and it was Doug,
Doug,
Stan hope.
Swartzman uh,
Tosh Kyle.
Who else fucking,
uh,
built wire,
a bunch of random like awesome people,
but uh,
patents on stage and Marin back when Marin still drank.
I think that was the last time you drank actually that weekend.
Marin wasn't drinking back then,
man wasn't drinking way back in the 80s no d start drinking again?
Yes.
Oh,
that was like during the relapse period.
I think I remember it because he talks about leaving the hotel and a friend who
was at the hotel was like,
yeah man,
when you left your luggage was sweating.
Like said it to me.
She was so hung over.
But patent was like,
you know,
doing him and Marin were just dropping in and places and this chick was so mad,
she got bumped.
She's like,
you fucking suck.
And in patents like I agree with you.
I agree with you.
She was mad at him because she got bumped and so she was saying he sucked.
Yeah.
She's just screaming at him from the audience and like she said,
you get up hunting.
Yeah.
Well I mean I was kind of like,
this is a free form room.
I got bumped,
but I get to watch Patton.
So she's a comic heckling.
Yeah.
Oh,
I know.
She never made it did show.
No,
Huh.
Yeah,
I mean,
and,
but it was that thing.
They were just like,
if you say I could be killing,
had been,
one guy would be,
this guy fucking blows.
And I'm like,
I believe that guy.
Damn it.
I don't want to,
that's the worst is when you're killing,
you see one person in the front row like this.
Yeah.
Like an old lady was scowling.
What?
Yeah.
I had an old lady like that at the store the other day.
Older Lady,
like she was like halfway into my act.
She still had this look on her face.
Like,
oh,
I don't know.
No,
I had her,
I hit her with this one bit and this one bed and she throws her head back and
then she's Howell and I'm like,
I got her.
Wow.
I got eyes she didn't want to give.
And that's a good,
that's a fun soda to cry when she was like all the sudden,
why God best feeling gave in.
Maybe it was the booze,
maybe the booze kicked in.